on va s'arrêter sur certains mots le
kremlin estiment que l'ukraine doit
idéalement être libéré et nettoyer des
nazis ce terme bien sûr qui renvoie à la
seconde guerre mondiale et au rôle clé
des soviétiques face aux nazis poutine
pioche dans l'histoire est là des formes
souvent on va en parler avec vous
florence gaillard bonjour florence
julien manche avec vous dans l'histoire
bien plus lointaines les origines de
l'ukraine l'ukraine a longtemps été sous
domination russe domination que
réaffirme aujourd'hui le chef du kremlin
oui c'est très clair pour vladimir
poutine il a d'ailleurs écrit en juillet
dernier il écrivait dans un long article
les russes et les ukrainiens ne forment
qu'une seule nation ou comme ça c'est
clair pour lui l'indépendance de
l'ukraine ne date que de 1991 c'est donc
un état très jeune très récent et qui
est incitée par l'occident à être
hostile à moscou en quelque sorte c'est
un état sous influence pour lui
occidentale mais qui n'a pas lieu d'être
d'où vient cette idée de nation unique
alors aller pour les historiens russes
le début de la russie les deux berceau
de là aussi c'est kiev la russie n'est
au 9e siècle à kiev fondée par des
vikings qui descendent vers les routes
de la soie on parle alors de larousse de
kiev vous voyez cette carte voyez là en
bleu c'est la principauté de kiev au 9e
siècle et elle démarre avec ce point
focal qu'est kiev qui est se trouve
actuellement dans l'ukraine donc
actuelle donc la russe de kiev c'est
donc au 9e
neuvième siècle en mille
le mot ou clerc lui vient le mot slave
qui signifie littéralement frontières
marche zone tampon et entre l'ukraine et
la hausse il n'y a pas de frontière
naturelle entre kiev et moscou lit à 850
km c'est à dire c'est paris marseille
club grossièrement donc si vous voulez
rouler dans un pays qui est en quelque
sorte qui n'est pas délimitée de la
russie et à l'est de l'ukraine la
population a toujours par les russes
d'ailleurs l'un des plus grands
écrivains russophones et ukrainiens
c'est nikolaï gogol et pourtant florence
les ukrainiens ont une langue une
culture et une histoire bien neuf oui
mais alors c'est une histoire très
complexe qui est faite de division ou
d'invasion et de domination au 14e
siècle les seniors sont polonais est
catholique et qu'est ce qu'ils font ils
réduisent les ukrainiens les paysans
ukrainiens orthodoxe en servage alors
que dans le reste de l'europe dans
l'ensemble on est plutôt en train de
libre réalisé et de sortir de
l'esclavagé du servage il ya deux
conséquences à cette domination
polonaise c'est d'abord la fuite des
paysans ukrainiens vers le sud et l'est
du pays ça c'est audio xvième siècle et
ensuite en 16 154 c'est l'ukrainien vous
demander la protection du tsar à moscou
ça c'est important à partir de là les
russes vous comptez sur les et craignent
un yves aux côtés notamment sur une
alliance militaire avec ce qu'on appelle
déjà les cosaques ukrainiens
mais l'alliance ça ne veut pas dire
domination c'est vrai c'est vrai alors
en au xviie siècle n'a encore dans un
rapport d'alliances et de deux services
rendus mais à la fin du xviiie siècle
c'est la pologne qui est à son tour
vaincu est partagé entre les grands
empires les empires autrichien les
empires russe et la prusse et là que
fait la russie eh ben elle fait son
marché comme on faisait à l'époque c'est
à dire qu'elle en profite pour faire
passer tout leur et territoire ukrainien
et la biélorussie sous l'autorité du
sart et ce n'est qu'en 1917 avec la fin
des romanov avec la fin de l'empiré
russe que l'ukraine espère prendre enfin
son indépendance indépendance qui sera
donc de courte durée alors oui parce que
du côté russe maintenant on a les
soviétiques et les soviétiques en 1922
créé l'union des républiques socialistes
soviétiques et bien sûr l'ukraine en
fait partie parce qu'en plus le crâne on
le sait c'est un pays fertile riches ont
dit que le crâne est le grenier à blé de
l'urss mais la politique sa ligne n va
avoir des conséquences énormes en
ukraine d'abord parce qu'il ya là des
coûts l'acquisation c'est à dire que les
riches paysans qui refusent le
collectivisme vont être assassiné et
cette désorganisation du système paysans
se solder par une grande famine en 1933
il va y avoir quatre millions de morts
alors que l'ukraine devienne le dire est
un grenier à blé donc cette famille
n'est complètement impensable insensé et
la population va énormément souffrir et
ça ça va laisser des traces d'un
population ukrainienne vous avez parlé
des nazis il ya quelques instants que
vont faire les nationalistes
d'ukrainiens quand les allemands vont
arriver lors de l'opération barbarossa
en 1941 eh bien ils vont accueillir à
bras ouverts la wehrmacht donc l'armée
allemande éd on va pas même par les deux
co la collaboration active dans ce
territoire qui va être complètement
occupé par les allemands c'est en
ukraine qu il y a les combats les plus
meurtriers
c'est en ukraine que commence la shoah
par balles ces espèces de faux c'est
atroce mon fusil la population les fait
tomber dans les ravins et ensuite on
rebouche les ravins bref ça va tu
absolument sanglante pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale est la conséquence de
cela c'est qu'après à la guerre quand
staline va l'emporter il va y aura
évidemment une énorme répression et un
énorme ménage une énorme opération qui
sera fait après guerre et donc
l'indépendance arrive en 1991 voilà donc
1991 c'est finalement assez récent à
cette époque là là aussi est au plus bas
et les républiques satellite en profite
pour s'émanciper quinze ans plus tard le
président iouchtchenko se rapproche de
l'union européenne et de l'otan et ça ça
n'est pas possible pour vladimir poutine
regarder cette carte tous les états qui
sont en blanc et en est donc l'ukraine
était dans le pacte de varsovie et ils
ont basculé dans l'otan est ce que c'est
possible pour vladimir poutine d'avoir
des pays de 2 qui appartiennent le temps
à ses frontières à ça à sa frontière
directe c'est pas possible et donc
évidemment il essaye de récré de
demeurer un excess finalement ce qui lui
reste faut pas oublier que le présent
russe a mis la pression sur la
population
il a en mai 2014 il a annexé la crimée
il a évidemment donné son soutien aux
deux basses ça a évidemment provoqué le
mouvement de maidan qu'on connaît à kiev
mais là encore finalement ce pays il
symbolise toute cette histoire d'un pays
divisé tiraillé entre sa culture
orthodoxe son histoire russophones et un
élan vers l'occident vers une certaine
liberté mais finalement l'histoire de
l'ukraine elle s'écrit actuellement et
on remet les choses dans l'ordre ils
voient de la désinformation merci
beaucoup florence gaillard